there's a common rumor that does the
rounds on the internet that at one point
pepsico was given a bunch of ships by
the ussr
and as a result of this transaction it's
often stated to have owned the sixth
largest navy in the world at that point
which obviously raises the question
did it well to begin the story often
deviates and when pepsico came into
ownership of this navy
some versions say that it was after the
second world war and some say it was in
the 60s and others the 80s with the last
one being correct since the transaction
occurred in 1989.
so what was this transaction so pepsi
wanted to continue
selling its drinks to the very large
internal market of the ussr
yet there was a snag the soviet ruble
was a closed currency meaning that
outside of the ussr it was basically
worthless
it couldn't be traded for dollars which
meant that foreign companies couldn't
take their profits out of the country
to counteract this pepsi made a deal in
the 1970s with a soviet vodka company
this meant that some of the profits from
the sale of that vodka globally would be
used to reimburse pepsi for its sales in
the ussr
as time went on though pepsi was
starting to lose money and so it
renegotiated
and this is where the ships come in
pepsi made a deal with the soviet
government and it was reported in the
usa that in return for the continued
sale of pepsi there the ussr would
instead pay with decommissioned naval
vessels which would then be sailed to
india and then sold for scrap to
reimburse the company some news outlets
reported that the deal had secured pepsi
17 submarines a frigate a destroyer and
a cruiser would this have been the sixth
largest navy in the world though
well no not even close it wasn't even in
the top 30 but for a private company
that would have been a fairly impressive
navy
there's also one other problem in that
it never happened the sale of these
warships for scrap was an idea floated
by the soviet government but it was
never accepted
every ship in the soviet navy which was
scrapped during this period is accounted
for
and in fact the deal saw the ussr build
freight ships for pepsi which could then
sell or lease them out as it saw fit
and so sorry to disappoint you all but
pepsi never owned a navy and even if it
had
it wasn't a very large one for what it's
worth though the deal was finalized in
1919 it remained in effect for 18 months
before the ussr collapsed and pepsi had
to start negotiations
all over again i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly moneymaker anthony
beckett the pastry section
danny maloney rob waterhouse moe aaron
the white
james castaneda jordan longley jerry
lamdin
marcus asner gustav swan john bailey
cooling castleman rasheed ali
spinning three plates filter oink oink
izzy david silverman maggie paxkowski
winston k wood spencer lightfoot robert
wetzel fortunate calf
lexi schwinn skye chappelle and marvin
cassal
it's all fun and games until coke gets
an aircraft carrier